el colorante alimenticio azul se puede
oxidar con blanqueador que contiene
hipoclorito un blanqueador común
contiene hipoclorito de sodio para
formar productos incoloros como se
representa en la ecuación de arriba
entonces este es el colorante que
reacciona con el hipoclorito y produce
un producto in color ahora un estudiante
usó un espectrofotómetro en una longitud
de onda de 635 nanómetros para estudiar
la absorban cya del colorante en el
tiempo durante el proceso de blanqueo
como estamos hablando de un colorante
azul me parece que esta es la longitud
de onda en el que la luz será
óptimamente absorbida por ese colorante
azul en el estudio el blanqueador está
presente en un gran exceso por lo que la
concentración de hipoclorito es
constante durante la reacción ok
el estudiante usó los datos del estudio
para generar las gráficas que se
muestran a continuación entonces aquí
están graficando vamos a ver en el eje
vertical tenemos la absorban cya y la
absorban cya la podemos ver como bueno
si tenemos una alta concentración de
colorante entonces tendremos una
absorban cja alta y si tenemos una baja
concentración de colorante entonces
tendremos una absorban cja baja entonces
esto lo podemos ver como una
aproximación de la concentración del
colorante alimenticio concentración del
colorante
y colorante alimenticio entonces aquí
tenemos una gráfica de la absorban cya
contra el tiempo aquí tenemos una del
logaritmo natural de la absorban cya
contra el tiempo y aquí tenemos 1 entre
la absorban cya contra el tiempo ok
vamos a ver las preguntas con base en
las gráficas de arriba cuál es el orden
de la reacción respecto al colorante
azul bueno vamos a ver si estuviéramos
hablando de una reacción de orden 0 eso
significaría que la velocidad de la
reacción es constante la velocidad de la
reacción es constante
y que es independiente de la
concentración del colorante entonces es
independiente
de la concentración
del colorante
y ese es nuestro caso
miren la velocidad no es constante y si
observamos la absorbencia que ya dijimos
que es una aproximación de la
concentración del colorante aquí arriba
la velocidad es muy rápida porque
tenemos una pendiente muy pronunciada y
después la pendiente va disminuyendo
conforme la concentración del colorante
disminuye con la reacción así que
definitivamente no es una reacción de
orden cero además si fuera una reacción
de orden 0 cuando grafica mos la
absorban cya que es una aproximación de
la concentración del colorante contra el
tiempo esperaríamos ver una línea recta
entonces si se encuentran con algo como
esto pueden decir ok eso parece una
reacción de orden cero pero ahora si
grafica mos el logaritmo natural de la
absorban cya que nuevamente ya sabemos
que es una aproximación del logaritmo
natural de la concentración del
colorante aquí tenemos una línea muy
clara
y si tenemos una línea pero lo que
quiero que vean es que esta es una forma
de darnos cuenta de que es una reacción
de primer orden entonces en una reacción
de primer orden de primer orden la
velocidad es proporcional proporcional a
la concentración
bueno mejor lo escribiré de otra forma
es proporcional a la concentración y
como es respecto al colorante entonces
es proporcional a la concentración del
colorante en este caso del colorante
azul ok y voy a escribir una ecuación
podemos decir que la velocidad en el
cambio de la concentración del colorante
respecto al tiempo si esto les parece
desconocido y no han tomado una clase de
cálculo no se preocupen solo ignoren lo
que voy a decir en los siguientes 20
segundos esto necesita ser proporcional
a la concentración del colorante
bueno entonces si ven esto sabrán que el
logaritmo natural de la concentración
del colorante respecto al bueno más bien
si grafica mos eso contra el tiempo
obtendremos una línea entonces esta es
la clave para saber que la reacción es
de primer orden primer orden bueno
aunque incluso lo pueden saber desde
aquí miren cuando la concentración del
colorante es alta la velocidad es alta
tenemos una pendiente muy pronunciada y
después cuando la concentración es baja
la pendiente también es menor así que
simplemente pueden analizar esta gráfica
y podrán saber que está ocurriendo algo
muy similar a esto entonces esta es una
reacción de primer orden y si pensáramos
en una reacción de segundo orden lo que
nos muestran es que en una reacción de
segundo orden al graficar uno entre la
absorban cya o uno entre la
concentración porque ya dijimos que la
absorban cya es una aproximación de la
concentración del color
durante contra el tiempo bueno aquí es
en donde tendríamos nuestra línea y en
este caso no la tenemos pero bueno en
este caso para contestar la pregunta
esta es una reacción de primer orden
respecto al colorante azul ok ahora
vamos con el inciso b se sabe que la
reacción es de primer orden
respecto al blanqueador ahora estamos
hablando del orden de la reacción con
respecto al blanqueador no al colorante
en un segundo experimento el estudiante
preparo soluciones de colorante y
blanqueador con concentraciones
diferentes a las que se usaron en el
primer experimento cuando las soluciones
fueron combinadas el estudiante observó
que la mezcla de la reacción alcanzó muy
rápidamente una absorban cya cercana a 0
es decir que cambia de color e incolora
muy rápido para corregir el problema
el estudiante propone tres posibles
modificaciones al experimento entonces
como el estudiante no
que la solución se torne incolora tan
rápido que debería hacer debería
aumentar la temperatura bueno aumentar
la temperatura solo hará que la reacción
ocurra todavía más rápido porque las
moléculas chocarán entre ellas con más
energía y más frecuentemente entonces
esta opción sólo hará que la mezcla se
vuelva incolora mucho más rápido y eso
es todo lo contrario a lo que se está
buscando vamos a tachar la ahora
aumentar la concentración del colorante
bueno esto tiene sentido aquí sólo dice
colorante pero sabemos que estamos
hablando del colorante azul entonces
como sabemos que la solución se vuelve
incolora muy rápido si agregamos más
colorante entonces tendremos una
absorban cya mayor y por lo tanto tomará
más tiempo para que el color de la
solución cambie entonces esta opción
podría ser y que hay de esta aumentar la
concentración de blanqueador bueno el
blanqueador al reaccionar con el
colorante
y es lo que hace que la solución sea
incolora entonces si aumentamos su
concentración tendremos una solución
incolora muy rápido y eso no es lo que
el estudiante busca así que también
vamos a tachar esto y nos quedamos con
esta opción de aumentar la concentración
del colorante y nos dicen enmarca la
propuesta de modificación vamos a
enmarcar la que podría corregir el
problema y explica cómo es que esa
modificación aumentará el tiempo en el
que la mezcla reacción ante alcanzará
una absorban cya cercana a 0 si
agregamos más colorante más colorante
resulta en una absorban cya inicial
mayor
absorban cya
inicial
mayor
y por lo tanto por lo tanto
más tiempo
para que la mezcla
alcance para que la mezcla alcance una
absorban cya cercana a 0
ok y finalmente vamos con el inciso c en
otro experimento un estudiante desea
analizar la oxidación del colorante
alimenticio rojo lo voy a subrayar un
colorante alimenticio rojo con
blanqueador que necesitaría modificar el
estudiante en el procedimiento
experimental original para determinar el
orden de la reacción con respecto al
colorante rojo bueno en general este es
un buen experimento graficaron en tres
formas diferentes que como ya vimos es
una buena forma de saber de qué orden es
la reacción de la que estamos hablando
pero al principio mencionamos esta
longitud de onda este es el valor que
corresponde a una longitud de onda que
es absorbida por el color azul pero si
ahora estamos hablando de un colorante
rojo bueno entonces tenemos que usar una
longitud de onda que pueda ser absorbida
por el colorante rojo y que será una
longitud de onda menor entonces lo que
habría que
es la longitud de onda modificar
y la longitud de onda
para que sea absorbida
absorbida
por el colorante rojo
es decir que será una longitud de onda
menor que coincida con el espectro de
luz que pueda ser absorbido por el
colorante rojo todo lo demás suena
completamente razonable